nine-one-one what is your emergency we
were in the middle of rehearsal in the
middle of a scene I heard some shot it
was like being in a war zone
[Music]
first everyone was still trying to
figure out how to process all of this
you always hear if the show must go on
when we all came back to school we all
knew what we needed to do this was
something we had to finish especially
something like this which is for kids
this is our begin again it is the most
important show that you're doing
probably ever we had to finish this to
show our community that we can't move on
we want to bring happiness to the school
again even though these bad things have
happened to us beautiful things can come
out of it deep the darkest stuff to make
him back to school I said I promise you
life is so good
[Music]
you